since it was launched in 1869 nature's
mission has been to communicate science
to wide audiences but above all to
communicate science to scientists nature
of course is famous for the for the
scientific research it publishes but it
also has what we call a front half which
is journalism by science reporters an
opinion by scientists and other experts
we're going to make the content more
compelling we are going to make the
stories and opinion even more relevant
to scientists lives we're going to
concentrate on scoops and deep analysis
that you can't find anywhere else we're
going to make it a must read if you look
at the way science itself is evolving
it's getting a more complex and
interdisciplinary there's a lot more
data around and nature has adapted to
reflect those purposes for science also
of course we have the internet and
scientists communicating all the time
that way so our online provision of
information has grown tremendously and I
guess above all the tempo of scientists
lives that speed it up everyone's more
busy including us so getting them the
information in an efficient way in terms
of navigation on the page and so on is a
key factor for them and for us so for
busy readers we present for example an
entire spread of news snippets that give
you essentially the week's most
important news at a glance we've
redesigned the way we present longer
stories so that it's completely clear
from the head and the stand first or the
deck as Americans call it what the story
is about so you can make a snap judgment
about how deep into the story you want
to get but also there are changes we've
made in just in terms of the journalists
that we've taken on we've really tried
to make the journalists as strong as
possible in uncovering news in
interesting ways so that the news we
publish isn't just a regurgitation of
events but more often we're actually
uncovering things that are happening for
ourselves we've reached the need for
reporters to to really go deep into
their be
from the bench all the way up to the
policy decisions that affect funding and
the direction of science so the
reporters go very deep and at the same
time we have this community of
journalists and editors who are
interested in many different disciplines
and talk all the time creating this
incredible ferment that allows us to
make connections to create packages to
play opinion pieces off news pieces to
basically make an organic magazine out
of all these specialties the content of
nature is improving the team that
creates that content with strengthened
and the mechanisms via which we deliver
that not just the printed magazine and
the website but also the mobile devices
the iPads and iPhones the e-readers and
the netbooks when scientists need access
to our information they can get it what
you'll see when you pick up nature after
September 23rd is first of all a very
different look it's been read as a
redesigned from stem to stern one goal
of this redesign is to make it easier to
navigate the first section of the
redesign nature presents news and
opinion that really is relevant to
what's happened over the past seven days
presented in a way that gives you a
quick scan of everything that that
matters it's happened in the world of
science over the past week it includes
highlights of the most recent research
published outside nature and it includes
opinion editorials and a new feature
that we're calling worldview which will
present views from experts on the latest
news it's essentially an op-ed page
that's followed by a section called news
in focus this presents stories where we
decided to go deeper where we saw an
opportunity for greater analysis or
context or backstory and these aren't
just good reads although they are that
these are a chance for you the
scientists to really immerse yourself in
issues that are that are relevant to you
even if not directly so the third
section of the redesign nature is called
comment and it brings together opinion
by experts book reviews arts reviews and
correspondence letters from readers
about other material in the front
this comment section is really part of a
conversation with our readership these
days journalism isn't a one-way street
journalists and opinion leaders telling
everybody else what's happened and what
to think we want our comment section to
be the beginning of a conversation to
spark a debate that goes on online
through our commenting service and in
the pages of nature we're really hoping
that the nature brand as it were will be
seen as a magazine brand as well as a
journal brand what I'm excited about is
taking part in creating the leading
magazine about the world of science one
that scientists will turn to every every
week or even every day online to find
out what is happening in their world the
changes that we're launching now are
really important but they're only one
step in a much longer journey the 23rd
of sep tember issue is for me a real
landmark in the history of nature that's
above all because of the research that's
gone behind it we've done a lot of
market research over the last year or
even two years really looking at what
people value in our content and we've
added some new types of content we've
added new shapes of content that is
we've done a redesign and a
restructuring so I think the impact on
the reader is going to be significantly
greater the reader of that book as it
were is going to get something just that
little bit more impactful and we're
going to go on doing this we know we've
we've evolved nature ever since I've
been a part of nature and there's no end
to that because we have to
you
you